why do humans return to Pandora in
avatar The Way of water is it for more
unobtainium James Cameron might just
surprise you at its core the Avatar
franchise is an outlandish science
fiction fantasy with its bizarre Bevy of
colorful creatures and Fantastical
Vistas the world of Pandora undeniably
Embraces its strange Concepts and finds
exciting ways to expand upon them
continuously however the franchise's way
of presenting these Larger than Life
ideas alongside its social commentary
remains most intriguing even if it's far
from the first sci-fi flick to do this
one of these attempts to connect the
franchise's wondrous settings to a real
world dilemma is with the special
Compound on obtainium in the first
avatar we learned that unoptanium acts
as a powerful superconductor which those
on Earth seek to use as a power source
given the energy crisis they are
experiencing however the navi people
forbid the mining of it as they view the
Tree of Souls where it's located as a
sacred place the environmental metaphor
may be pretty on the nose but it's
nevertheless an integral part of the
story Avatar tries to tell about our
inner connection with nature and how far
we are willing to fight for it I'm a
warrior like you I'm supposed to fight
it's all the more surprising that film
sequel Avatar the way of water never
mentions unobtainium that's right the
very element that caused the central
conflict in Pandora's history is not
given a single mention in the way of
water so what does the absence of this
crucial substance mean for the greater
Avatar story moving forward the term
unobtainium is not present in avatar The
Way of water but that doesn't mean the
idea behind the substance is lost the
film sees Colonel Miles courage return
in an avatar body to take down Jake
Sully and his family when Sully decides
to move his family beyond the outskirts
of their Forest Home they join the
mechano tribe of the ocean who teaches
the family their ways amongst the most
crucial aspects of the metcina way of
life comes their connection with the
whale-like creatures The Tokens The
People hold the intelligent creatures in
extremely high regard seeing them as
siblings and forming lifelong
connections with the animals from birth
in an attempt by courage and his band of
goons to lure Sully from hiding they
team up with a ship of Tolkien Hunters
who help kill the animal to cause
distress to the Medina clap however
after killing the animals The Hunters
drill into their heads and take out a
Gloppy liquid that is incredibly
valuable with even a small canister
worth millions in this way the tolkiens
stand in as a similar piece of symbolism
that the unobtainium did in the first
film as a precious natural resource that
Humanity seeks to exploit it serves the
message here but even more significantly
it paints a picture of what we can
expect in the franchise's future the
seemingly forgotten unobtanium might
confuse viewers coming into Avatar the
way of water as an essential plot point
in the first film it seems natural that
this long-awaited sequel finds new ways
to expand and build upon what we already
know about the valuable substance but
just as the wave water explores new and
exciting lands in Pandora instead of
staying in the same places as
predecessor the film chooses to evolve
its thematic nature as well this family
is our Fortress keep in mind that the
way of water takes place more than a
decade after the first film's events in
that time the energy crisis on Earth has
likely taken over or if not is very
close to doing so is unobtainium still
strong enough to solve the issue even if
it proves powerful it's more than likely
that Colonel korich and this gang will
find similarly valuable resources
throughout Pandora and find some way to
exploit them for their own use the war
against humanity is about more than
protecting the navi people and the life
on Pandora but the heart and soul of the
planet itself that keeps everything in
check the way of water tells us that
there is no one little piece that
matters as much as it is the entirety of
the world that deserves saving
foreign